[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public on est
ensemble tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat pour
donner du sens à l'actualité avec nos
experts un dialogue de source sur fond
de violence grandissante c'est ce qui
résume le climat social à la veille de
la dixième journée de mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites et
pourtant le porte-parole du gouvernement
se veut optimiste pour la suite
on va se retrouver autour de la table
avec les syndicats mais ils aiment leur
pays ils aiment les salariés ils les
défendent il y a beaucoup de combats
qu'il mène à côté des 64 ans comment
renouer le dialogue qu'est-ce qui
pourrait stopper la spirale
radicalisation répression en débat dans
une minute et puis juste après on fera
un pas de côté pour voir comment cette
crise politique française est vue de
l'étranger après l'annulation de la
visite d'État de Charles III après les
violences du week-end à sainte-soly ne
cours autour du projet de méga bassid et
puis avec ses poubelles qui continuent
de déborder à Paris c'est aussi l'image
de notre pays qui s'habille à 18 mois
des Jeux olympiques mais d'abord on
regarde comment Elisabeth borne tente de
reprendre la main la première ministre
ouvrait ce lundi missionné par le
Président de la République une séquence
de consultation qui doit durer trois
semaines Cécile Sixou
à la veille de l'acte 10 des
manifestations Elisabeth borne semble
sereine pendant plus de deux heures cet
après-midi la chef du gouvernement a
présenté sa feuille de route au
président de la République et au chef de
fil de la majorité pour calmer la colère
dans le pays ce weekend elle a déjà
annoncé ne plus avoir recours aux 49-3
sauf pour les textes budgétaires mais
aussi promis d'être plus à l'écoute des
Français nous connaissons l'état
d'esprit et les inquiétudes de nos
concitoyens
nous devons être à l'écoute des doutes
et parfois des colères exprimés dans les
mouvements sociaux qui dépassent
largement la réforme des retraites il
s'agit d'une demande de justice il
s'agit de prendre en compte l'évolution
de notre rapport au travail et d'offrir
de vrais perspectives à chacun dans les
trois semaines à venir Elisabeth borne a
prévu d'ouvrir le dialogue avec les
parlementaires et les parties
d'opposition pour élargir sa majorité
mais aussi avec les syndicats notamment
sur sa future loi pleine emploi une main
tendue d'ores et déjà refusée par
Laurent Berger ce matin le secrétaire
général de la CFDT demande un geste fort
sur les retraites avant de discuter avec
le gouvernement du 10 janvier jusqu'il y
a encore 5-6 jours on avait zéro contact
vous veniez discuter du travail nous on
dit ok on va on veut venir discuter du
travail mais aussi discuter des
retraites on nous dit même non mais vous
ne pouvez pas venir voir le prénom de la
République si vous discutez des
retraites mais vous imaginez pas quand
même qu'il y a plus de il y a 2 millions
de personnes dans la rue jeudi dernier
et qu'on va pas discuter des retraites
si on est invité à discuter à l'Élysée
demain l'Inter syndical appelle à la
mobilisation dans la capitale près de
5000 policiers et gendarmes devraient
être déployés je pourrais tout de suite
mes invités
bonsoir et bienvenue directeur délégué
de l'institut Harris interactif France
venait avec un sondage dont on va
découvrir les résultats ensemble en
exclusivité Bastien François bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur de
sciences politiques à l'Université Paris
impantéon Sorbonne et Mathieu croissanto
guitariste politique bonsoir Mathieu
bonsoir bienvenue à vous le premier mot
tiens qui me vient à l'esprit pour
caractériser la situation politique
unchaine business c'est le mot impasse
c'est pas très original en disant ça
sauf que ça fait 10 jours qu'on dit ça
et que depuis il y a eu beaucoup de
prises de parole du pré dans la
République de la première ministre bref
il y a pas de il y a pas tissu en tout
cas c'est l'impression qu'il nous donne
ou que l'on a ce qu'il y a c'est aussi
le terme de dialogue de saut qu'on a
employé dans le sujet et pourtant on
n'arrête pas de rajouter du dialogue on
voit bien que ça ne fait que creuser
justement ce déficit alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en fait tous les
gestes qui sont considérés comme des
gestes en faveur de la reprise des
négociations sont en fait des gestes qui
ne font que la fermer parce qu'il faut
pas oublier que quand Elisabeth borne se
dit prête à recevoir les syndicats etc
et comme le dit Laurent Berger c'est
pour parler d'autre chose donc on voit
bien qu'on est dans une situation de
blocage alors c'est vrai que sous la
Cinquième République on a connu
plusieurs fois des situations de blocage
dont cette longueur et dans cette
fermeté c'est quand même relativement
inédit puisque c'est vrai que il y a des
armes constitutionnelles il y a des
armes politiques pour essayer de
répondre à la colère du pays et on voit
bien qu'ici on a un président de la
République qui nous l'a réaffirmé
d'ailleurs sur les ondes la semaine
dernière qui tient ferme non seulement
sa position mais qui estime en fait en
quelque sorte que il n'y a pas de crise
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'en fait
on a même pas de partage sur le constat
entre lui et la rue et justement les
personnes qui s'estiment mécontente de
ce projet de loi c'est qu'on a le
sentiment que le Président de la
République de toute façon en jambe cette
situation comme si elle était juste
c'est ce qu'Elizabeth borne disait
d'ailleurs à ses ministres un mauvais
moment à passer donc ils sont encore
dans ce champ lexical là et apparemment
c'est quelque chose qui est amené à
continuer jusqu'à quand c'est la
question on donnera les résultats du
sondage dans un instant j'en ai une
limite mais effectivement là-dessus ce
côté un mauvais moment quoi comme si
c'était déjà derrière eux quoi bon ben
voilà il a fallu utiliser le 49-3 c'est
un peu ce que disait Olivier Veyron ce
matin aussi sur BFM TV c'est ce
sentiment que c'est un peu derrière le
derrière derrière le gouvernement vous
allez ressenti ça aussi mais en tout cas
dans la posture ça c'est certain
de la communication c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait vous prenez l'interview d'Emmanuel
Macron mercredi dernier vous prenez
également les propos d'Olivier Véran le
message qui souhaite faire passer c'est
globalement nous avons décidé que cette
réforme irait jusqu'au bout nous n'avons
pas varié un pouce alors même qui a eu
des centaines de milliers voire des
millions de manifestants depuis quelques
semaines et que dans ce contexte là
alors même qu'il s'agissait d'un
engagement présidentiel nous allons
obtenir cet engagement présidentiel
réforme des retraites changements de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite donc
on est à 64 et non pas 65 ans comme
initialement prévu et d'une manière
d'une autre les Français sont pas
résignés mais en tout cas donc toujours
considéré c'est à dire que ils n'ont
jamais pensé que d'une manière ou d'une
autre le gouvernement allait amené à
dire au moment de l'examen au Parlement
que on allait revenir ou amender les
principales dispositions pas plus qu'il
ne pense aujourd'hui que Emmanuel Macron
ne va pas promulguer la loi en dernière
instance on y reviendra en détail de
notre sondage mais effectivement
la seule issue elle est presque proposée
on entendait Laurent Berger Vincent
c'est d'appuyer sur pause sauf qu'appuie
sur pause on sait bien ce qui se passe à
ça ça veut dire que c'est très fort mais
elle sera elle sera pas reportée elle ne
verra jamais le jour
il y a une différence entre retirer et
appuyer sur pause quand même il y a
quand même on perd moins la face on peut
reconstruire des choses parce que quoi
qu'il arrive il va falloir reconstruire
quoi qu'il arrive
pour une raison toute simple c'est les
résultats du législatives de juin quoi
qu'il arrive il faut avoir construire
des choses or en l'état que ce soit avec
les forces sociales et les syndicats
mais aussi on en parle pas beaucoup là
actuellement mais avec les groupes
politiques à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat
les choses sont vraiment très très
abîmées oui alors qu'il y a eu des
textes qui ont été votés
ça passe à la trappe quoi parce que bon
c'est pas des textes qui ont aussi
l'importance de la réforme des retraites
c'est pas des textes qui sont en tout
cas dans tous les cas à la mesure des
enjeux
qui nous attendent que enfin des défis
de ce qui sont devant nous je vous
rappelle il y a une semaine en même
temps que cet épisode là il y avait le
sixième rapport du GIEC qui nous disait
qu'on a 10 ans devant nous bon disons
avant la catastrophe alors déjà c'est un
petit peu stressant hein bon mais ça
veut dire qu'il faut des politiques
structurales très importantes et des
politiques qui soient efficaces qui
soient juste et qui soit validé le plus
largement possible l'immobilisme c'est
pas une option c'est c'est je pense que
tout le monde est lancé
dans un climat comme celui-là dans ce
cadre-là pose
accompagné d'un véritable changement de
méthode parce que le problème c'est
aussi la
le changement de méthode ça fait des
mois qu'on nous en parle le soir même
des résultats de l'élection président de
la République des échangements de
méthodes il en parlait déjà au moment
des gilets jaunes
et là il faut donner du contenu à ce
changement en fait ce que ce qu'on
entend et ce qui est sous-entendu dans
la proposition de Laurent Berger c'est
une sorte de grande conférence sociale
sauf que ça ne sonnerait d'abord comme
un échec pour Emmanuel Macron on est
bien d'accord unchard bizna mais c'est
peut-être ceux qui permettraient ensuite
de reprendre la main et de ne pas être
condamné à l'immobilisme mais en fait
est-ce que je veux dire un échec à
première vue mais peut-être finalement
un succès à venir et encore une fois un
échec limité comme on disait c'est à
dire que on a depuis le mois de janvier
de toute façon deux discours
complètement opposés on a la majorité
qui veut aller au bout de ce principe de
l'âge légal et de l'augmentation des
cotisations ce sur quoi l'Inter
syndicale a dit que si on travaillait
sur l'âge légal et les cotisations de
toute façon elle ne ferait pas partie du
jeu donc on a quelque chose de
totalement fermé depuis le départ si
alors mieux vaut tard que jamais
si même après le vote de cette loi on
arrive au moins à se remettre autour de
la table et je cite le président de la
République qui a dit ça la semaine
dernière et bien ça serait quand même
bienvenu pour tout le monde parce que
comme on l'a dit il faut arriver à se
mettre d'accord sur quelque chose
suspendre
susmilier comme on l'avait fait avec le
Contrat Première Embauche ça sent
vraiment très très loin des méthodes du
président à l'heure actuelle un grand
référendum une dissolution apparemment
il a pas l'air constitutionnellement
d'avoir encore envie d'actionner ce type
de levier donc la conférence sociale
c'est presque la réponse à minima de ce
qu'il pourrait concéder pour avoir de la
continuité oui à condition qu'on y parle
de l'enjeu parce que on a eu quand même
une séquence sur les retraites un peu
particulière parce qu'on a eu une
concertation au soleil avec les
syndicats menés à l'automne ou en fait
en langage syndical on dit qu'on a
promené le chien c'est à dire qu'on a
parlé pour ne rien dire pour la bonne et
simple raison que le gouvernement ne
dévoilait pas l'exécutif ne dévoilait
pas le contenu de sa réforme est-ce que
c'est 65 64 il ne voulait pas répondre
est-ce qu'il y aura si est-ce qu'il y
aura ça il ne voulait pas répondre donc
il y a eu des concertations sur des sur
des
de la méthode de la réforme des
retraites sur des sujets annexes sur un
peu sur les carrières longues des choses
comme ça mais il y a pas eu on n'a pas
discuté du fond de la réforme et donc
après si on discute on se remet autour
de la table et qu'on discute pas du fond
tout ça n'aura été qu'une gigantesque
parenthèse décider et voulu par
l'exécutif sans autre forme de
négociation que ce soit c'est un échec
patant de
j'allais dire pas de la méthode Macron
parce qu'il a fait d'autres choses
pendant son premier quinquennat mais en
tout cas sur d'autres démocratie sociale
sur la façon qu'on vient de négocier
avec les partenaires sociaux on est
revenu des années en arrière Emmanuel
Macron n'oublions pas qu'il serait
clamer de la gauche de Michel Rocard qui
était plutôt du côté du contrat que de
la loi qui était quelqu'un qui était
nourri soit disant biberonnés ce
dialogue avec les partenaires sociaux
les a écrasés pendant son premier
quinquennat aujourd'hui on n'est pas au
point non retour mais il y a une
défiance absolue que deux ou trois
gestes ou deux ou trois discussions
comme ça de coin de table à mon avis de
parviendront pas résoudre pour la suite
et pour lancer les champions et ensuite
on commence avec les résultats c'est que
le bouton pause il existe dans la
Constitution en réalité réussir c'est la
possibilité pour le président de la
République de demander une nouvelle
délibération de l'assemblée il reste
dans le chemin démocratique comme il
disait bon et et l'avantage c'est que
vous savez le président dit toujours qui
que il la mettre le maître des horloges
faire ça ça veut dire qu'il retrouve la
maîtrise du temps politique c'est-à-dire
après il peut en faire ce qu'il veut il
peut prendre du temps il peut même se
dire bon ok c'est vrai que c'était pour
l'équilibre en 2030 on peut être qu'il
faut on peut prendre encore 6 mois etc
vous voyez c'est à dire que c'est pas
c'est pas la défaite elle est l'échec
est déjà là en réalité
ce 49-3 a été vécu alors attends ou a
raison l'usage de ce 49-3 était vécu
comme l'aveu d'un échec bon
donc là je crois qu'il y a il y a une
arme dont il dispose qui lui permettrait
ça serait pas la façon de Chirac ou vous
souvenez peut-être de Chirac le le jour
de la communication de la loi sur le CPE
qui intervient à la télévision et qui
dit cette chose stupéfiante je demande à
mes ministres de ne pas appliquer la loi
et quand même quelque chose d'assez bon
c'est c'est du Jacques Chirac mais
il y a une façon finalement assez
élégante qui serait dans ce discours de
je poursuis le cheminement démocratique
de la discussion alors je dis pas que
c'est qui serait très heureux le
président de faire ça mais entre être ne
pas être entre cette petite défaite où
cette petite contrition des
constitutionnel et être bloqué pendant 4
ans être obligé à une dissolution ou il
n'aura même pas la majorité relative
qu'il a aujourd'hui bon il suffit de
voir l'élection de partielle de dimanche
alors j'en délais Lévis comme prévu vous
nous révéler les résultats de de ce
sondage Toluna Harry interactive pour
Public Sénat et AEF info à la veille de
cette dixième journée d'action déjà il y
a le comment évolue l'opinion en général
le cette cette masse vraiment très
majoritaire d'opposants à la réforme et
au contraire ce socle qui était l'une et
l'autre relativement solide de de
partisans ça bouge ça bouge pas ça bouge
et ça bouge même de manière un peu
surprenante on aurait pu s'attendre
qu'après le fait qu'il y ait le 49-3 le
fait qu'elle soit adoptée le fait qu'il
est la prise de parole de la part du
président de la République voire même
qui a eu des violences soit directement
connectées soit déconnecté de la réforme
qui puisse avoir une forme de tentation
des Français de se dire en fait au final
je vais un peu moins être opposé à la
réforme ça n'est pas le cas on a
aujourd'hui plus des deux tiers des
Français qui se déclarent opposés à la
réforme 69% 69%. ce chiffre là n'a
jamais été atteint depuis le début de la
mobilisation
au niveau que l'on a et même quand on
regarde dans le détail en terme
d'intensité vous avez même un français
sur de pratiquement qui se déclare tout
à fait opposé et avec un phénomène qui
est un phénomène de polarisation bien
plus marqué que par le passé c'est à
dire que les proches de la majorité
présidentielle et les proches des
républicains déclarent beaucoup plus que
par le passé qui sont favorables à la
réforme et ça c'est peut-être un des
points qui fait qu'Emmanuel Macron reste
sur la position
tandis que ceux qui étaient plutôt
critiques le sont encore plus notamment
ceux qui situe le plus à gauche et le
plus à droite sur l'échiquier politique
donc niveau de rejet le plus élevé et
polarisation et puis alors ce qui est
intéressant parce qu'on a on a toujours
été essayé et essayer de regarder aussi
alors moi je dis souvent fatalisme c'est
peut-être pas le terme que vous employez
mais est-ce que les Français continuent
de dire de toute façon elle sera
appliquée elle sera promulguée cette
règle c'est le cas pour cette française
sur 10 et là pour le coup qu'on soit
favorable ou opposé à la réforme qu'on
soit soutien du président de la
République ou contempteur de celui-ci on
voit bien que la posture globale est
sensiblement perçue de la même manière
et donc avec la perception que de toute
façon Emmanuel Macron ira jusqu'au bout
c'est une semi surprise parce que ça
s'inscrit dans la droite ligne de tout
ce qu'on avait pu mesurer également
depuis janvier dernier ou globalement le
français quand on leur posait la
question par rapport à l'adoption et à
la posture du gouvernement non pas du
président de la réplique le législatif
et l'exécutif incarné par le
gouvernement la perception c'est qu'il y
aurait aucun amendement et que
finalement le passage à son 4 ans parce
que c'est ce type de ce site dont il est
véritablement en question se ferait quoi
qu'il en coûte alors il y a une autre
dimension en hiver un peu plus tard
c'est la dimension évidemment de d'une
spirale de violence radicalisation
répression que vous avez aussi là aussi
les enseignements du sondage sont
vraiment intéressants mais Mathieu je
voudrais qu'on vienne on a commencé à
l'évoquer avec Bastien François sur la
question de la méthode alors le
président a redit ça c'était mercredi à
la télévision sa volonté de changer de
méthode oui entre nous ça commence à
ressembler on en parlait à une promesse
éculée parce que depuis le lance son
lancement en politique en fait Emmanuel
Macron a cessé d'annoncer sa volonté de
faire différemment c'était même le
paradigme de sa première campagne
présidentielle enterré l'ancien monde
pour faire de la politique autrement
donner naissance à un nouveau monde
alors on connaît la suite appel
installer à l'Élysée le président de la
République a surpris tout le monde
notamment par le classicisme avec lequel
il a conçu sa fonction plus verticale
que moi tueur les Français attendaient
un droit d'inventaire une nouvelle ère
ils ont eu Jupiter et pourtant à chaque
crise lors de son premier quinquennat le
chef de l'État a tenté renouveler cette
martingale vous en parliez annoncé à
corps et à crier après la crise des
gilets jaunes après la crise covid lors
de la dernière campagne présidentielle
ou encore la semaine dernière la
nouvelle méthode c'est un carnet dans
des refrains éculés aussi plus de
dialogue plus d'écoute c'est ce qu'on
entend à chaque fois et dans des
dispositifs pour le coup à géométrie
variable ça va du grand débat la
convention citoyenne en passant par le
Conseil national de la refondation
autant d'innovations qui ont parfois
permis de faire retomber la pression je
pense au grand débat notamment mais qui
n'ont pas réussi en revanche à faire
progresser la culture du consensus du
compromis dans notre pays ni évidemment
à changer les processus de décision ni
même peut-être à changer la culture
politique du président alors est-ce
qu'il pourrait en être différent cette
fois-ci mercredi dernier Emmanuel Macron
a fixé une feuille de route difficile
sinon une mission impossible à Isabelle
borne qui tient deux expressions bâtir
un programme de gouvernement et élargir
la majorité il a ajouté dans la foulée
vous souvenez cette petite phrase pas
très sereine j'espère qu'elle y arrivera
donc ça sent pas très bon il y a alors
Elisabeth borne non plus n'en est pas à
son coup d'essai et vous y faisiez
allusion tout à l'heure Thomas dans son
discours de politique générale en
juillet dernier elle avait aussi promis
de faire différemment concertation
co-construction compromis et elle est
plutôt parvenue au gré de majorité
construite texte par textes avant de se
crasher sur cette réforme des retraites
et là le défi qu'il attend est
évidemment des plus complexes alors à la
décharge la première liste elle n'est
pas seule en cause dans cette affaire il
faut la fois composé on en parlait avec
un échiquier politique en morceaux un
omniprésident j'avais un président
omniprésent mais voilà qui se mêle de
tout une opinion chauffée à blanc et des
pare-soleil plus que mes filles alors
s'il y a une nouvelle méthode board ça
pourrait consister en quoi mais pour
l'instant rien de très nouveau sous le
soleil cette espèce de tour de
passe-passe de parler de tout sauf du
sud de l'éléphant dans la pièce du sujet
qui fâche et puis la nouvelle méthode
elle se borne pour l'instant à trois
semaines de concertation avec tenez-vous
à votre chaise les groupes
parlementaires les partis politiques les
élus locaux les partenaires sociaux tant
mieux mais ça n'est quand même pas très
très nouveau j'en ai assez classique le
souhait de faire des textes plus courts
et plus technique ça c'est une autre
option qui avait été soulevée par par le
président et voilà pour l'instant on en
est là on verra bien alors c'est quand
même des vieilles ficelles qui semblent
bien loin du renouveau démocratique que
les Français attendent et qui ne pourra
pas à mes yeux vraisemblablement voir le
jour sans une clarification du paysage
politique sinon ça va être très très
compliqué à faire autrement dit de
nouvelles élections de nouvelles
élections qui dit nouvelle éditions
évidemment on pense à la dissolution
vous l'avez évoqué rapidement tout à
l'heure alors politiquement on peut
imaginer on sait jamais mais une
élection jamais joué mais avant avant
qu'elle n'ait lieu mais qu'elle
affaiblirait Emmanuel Macron et le camp
présidentiel mais est-ce que
constitutionnellement c'est pas dans la
logique de ce qu'on est en train de
vivre une solution alors la dissolution
on a conçoit de différentes manières au
départ si on veut vraiment reprend sa
philosophie britannique la dissolution
c'est plus une consolidation des
majorités à un moment de sentir aussi
quand le peuple a besoin de de se
prononcer à la française sous la
Cinquième République en tout cas général
de Gaulle la plusieurs fois considéré
comme une solution de sortie de crise
alors on a au moins l'exemple de 62 qui
est assez topique ou le général de
Gaulle est mise en minorité puisqu'on
lui renverse et c'est la seule fois sous
la Cinquième République son gouvernement
son Georges Pompidou donc il le prend
très mal évidemment il le renomme dans
la foulée il dit sous l'Assemblée
nationale mais en disant quelque chose
qui finalement fait partie du pacte
républicain et bien au moins le peuple
tranchera en quelque sorte entre les
conflits d'organes entre l'exécutif et
législatif deuxième fois en 68 on a
vraiment un dialogue de sourd qui l'a
encore s'installe entre le président et
sa base et le peuple puisqu'on a un
discours qui qui ressemble presque à
certains égards au discours du président
de la République de la semaine dernière
avec la République ne cèdera rien je
suis une partie de l'Ordre etc et pour
autant il propose la dissolution ensuite
là encore pour donner au peuple les
moyens de se prononcer et on sait qu'il
était aussi très friand de l'usage du
référendum pour avoir toujours une
connexion en quelque sorte avec le
peuple parce que il y a la légitimité
élective mais il y a la légitimité
sociale aussi qui fait que on a besoin
de se sentir reconnecté alors est-ce que
là le président de la République pour
relaxer alors constitutionnellement rien
de plus simple il s'agit d'un petit au
déjeuner avec le président des deux
assemblées pour que ça soit acté c'est
un pouvoir propre donc il peut
l'actionner quand il le souhaite
néanmoins c'est vrai qu'on a le
sentiment que ça ne fait pas partie de
la méthode Macron dont on a parlé alors
la nouvelle ou l'ancienne je ne sais pas
trop mais c'est vrai qu'on a un
président qui a toujours très peu
utilisé les leviers constitutionnels de
sortie de crise qui était à ça à sa
disposition et là aussi pas de grands
scoop en matière de présidentialisation
de la 5e République depuis de Gaulle
plus personne vraiment n'utilise ces
arguments là à part le remaniement
peut-être pour donner des messages de
sortie de crise au peuple et puis c'est
important il en sortirait pas forcément
une majorité plus plus claire ou plus
stable
de nouvelles élections législatives dans
un régime parlementaire théoriquement la
France est un régime type parlementaire
un régime parlementaire c'est évidemment
la sortie de crise évidemment bon le
problème c'est que la particularité de
notre système politique c'est que le
Président de la République est
déconnecté de ce circuit électrique donc
ça veut dire que si vous faites
si vous faites des législatives
anticipées qui peut évidemment faire
on peut raisonnablement
imaginer qu'il n'aura pas une majorité
absolue mais on n'est même pas sûr qu'il
y aura une majorité
là on se retrouvait dans une sorte de
cohabitation assez bizarre parce que la
cohabitation généralement elle s'est
toujours faite avec un fait majoritaire
en fait simplement le fait majoritaire
bénéficier au Premier ministre bon là on
serait peut-être là on rentrerait dans
quelque chose de d'extrêmement compliqué
alors pour les constitutionnalisme je
dois vous dire
ça nous donnerait matière à faire des
cours plus rigolos mais pour la France
je suis pas sûr que ça soit que ça soit
la bonne solution non en réalité la très
grande difficulté je pense pour le
président de la réplique s'il y a pas
d'instrument constitutionnel il faut
faire de la politique voilà et donc
faire la politique c'est pour ça que je
disais la question de la pose
c'est une question politique mais parce
que sinon tout le reste ça n'aura pas
vraiment de sens il pourra pas mettre du
sens et bon faire la politique alors
dans les circonstances actuelles dans
l'état de fragmentation de l'Assemblée
nationale avec cette histoire déjà voilà
c'est vrai que c'est très très difficile
je reviens vers vous et on repart sur le
sondage juste après sans faute
évidemment j'en ai une vie mais j'ai
parfois l'impression que le la l'issue
pourrait venir du Conseil
constitutionnel il y a une espèce de
acide Conseil constitutionnel pouvait
nous retoquer ce texte finalement ça
nous arrangerait en tout cas ça c'est
dur ça c'est pas c'est pas personne va
le dire en ligne évidemment mais alors
c'est à quelle échéance et comment ça
peut se passer alors le Conseil
constitutionnel doit se prononcer dans
un délai d'un mois la première ministre
n'a pas d'après nos informations à
actionner l'urgence donc il ne se
prononcera pas en huit jours un délai
d'un mois que généralement il n'épuise
pas donc on peut espérer trois semaines
depuis sa saisine du 22 mars c'est ma
mémoire est bonne
qu'est-ce qu'on peut espérer de lui
alors les saisissons on espère beaucoup
une censure totale par rapport au fait
que cette procédure a manqué à la clarté
du débat parlementaire par rapport au
fait que le 47 ans n'aurait pas dû être
utilisé néanmoins là encore il faut
rester sur
le véhicule législatif de la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative on doit rappeler quand
même que le Conseil constitutionnel
censure rarement pour des motifs de
procédure ou alors pour vraiment des
motifs de procédure très acquis comme la
méconnaissance du droit de priorité on
saisit une assemblée plutôt qu'une autre
la méconnaissance des deux parties de la
loi de finances on vote la deuxième
avant de voter la première donc voilà
les deux cas c'est assez subjectif et la
des débats il faut savoir que ça a été
dégagé une fois en 2005 et que depuis
lors il y a pas eu une seule censure sur
ce motif donc le Conseil constitutionnel
la dégagé pour par égard à la courtoisie
parlementaire qui doit faire partie des
Sénats de parlementaires normalement
mais on n'a pas vraiment si vous voulez
matière à censure constitutionnelle
depuis l'or en tout cas jamais à part en
2016 une réserve d'interprétation pour
quelques amendements mais le conseil ne
sait jamais fondé là-dessus donc à mon
avis ça me semble très difficile
d'attendre du Conseil cautionné d'une
science sur totale est-ce que pour
autant le Conseil conditionnel sera
dépourvu le moyen pour dire que par
exemple le projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale ne lui semblait
pas le bon véhicule moi je ne crois pas
parce que je pense notamment en
censurant les cavaliers sociaux alors
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est les
dispositions qui n'ont en fait rien à
faire dans une loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale et Dieu sait si dans le
cadre de cette réforme elles sont
nombreuses les dispositions qui n'ont
rien à voir avec l'équilibre 2023 et
bien on censurance là le Conseil
constitutionnel pourrait passer le
message que nos futurs réformes des
retraites ne devraient pas passer par ce
véhicule là donc je pense que la voie
médiane pourrait tout à fait être
choisie par lui pour donner ce message
pour le futur au gouvernement mais
la loi s'appliquerait alors il y a un
autre événement qui est venu rajouter de
l'inquiétude à ce climat qui est déjà
lourd c'est la manifestation du week-end
à Sainte-Souline affrontement entre les
forces de l'ordre et certains opposants
à ce projet de méga bassine il y a eu
des dizaines de blessés des deux côtés
on a appris en cette fin l'après-midi
qui avait un deuxième manifestant qui
était dans le coma donc deux
manifestants sont ce soir dans le coma
ce matin c'était ce matin sur France
Inter le ministre de la transition
écologique justifiait l'interdiction de
la manifestation avec ses mots ce sont
des dizaines de couteaux de machettes de
cocktail Molotov de pierre de pavés qui
ont été saisis par les gendarmes tout au
long de la journée et vous avez vu les
images vous avez vu des gens jeter des
chandelles romaines ou des tirs de
mortiers sur les gendarmes et on
voudrait nous faire croire qu'à la fin
la responsabilité elle serait du côté
des forces de l'ordre cette
manifestation je le redis elle était
interdite contenue des précédentes elle
était interdite également compte tenu
des notes qui permettaient de s'attendre
à un millier d'événements radicalisés
alors j'en ai mis il faut expliquer
est-ce que le sondage dont on parle ce
soir a été fait après les violences de
sainte solide la réponse est oui il a
été fait aujourd'hui toute la journée
donc on est très bien donc c'est
important de le préciser qu'est-ce qui
ressort peut-être sur et je vais
inverser ce que j'avais prévu je
préviens la régie tout de suite sur
l'action des forces de l'ordre est-ce
que les Français comment les Français
jugent l'action des forces de l'ordre la
question précise ne revenait pas sur
Sainte solide mais normalement sur la
mobilisation dans le cadre mais la
réforme
forcément un petit bruit qui peut
exister même si on a vu sur la réforme
des retraites que pour le reste ça n'a
pas eu tellement d'influence quoi qu'il
en soit il y a une perception en fait de
la part de près de la moitié des
Français qui a un usage qui apparaît
comme étant disproportionné de la force
de la part de de la puissance grand
public alors 45% absolument 45% avec un
point qui est attendu c'est à dire que
quand vous regardez les personnes qui
sont plutôt à gauche ou l'échiquier
politique disent oui il y a vraiment un
aspect qui apparaît comme étant
disproportionné lorsque vous interrogez
les proches des républicains et les
proches de la majorité présidentielle
qui globalement ou le sentiment que
c'était au bon au bon niveau mais les
proches du rassemblement national dont
on a plutôt la perception qu'ils sont
plutôt du côté des forces de l'ordre
donc un peu tout le sentiment qu'ils
sont du côté de l'ordre de la sécurité
pour caricature un peu eux aussi se
rangent à l'idée qui a eu un usage qui
leur apparaît à leurs yeux trop
important de la part des forces de
l'ordre justement des différents moyens
qui étaient mis à leur disposition donc
on a ce regard là qui est porté
peut-être qu'il faut mettre en regard
avec l'autre question qu'on a posé
également sur la perception qui existe
parce qu'en fait et est-ce qu'on pour
autant on est d'une manière globale dans
la cité française à approuver le recours
à la violence de la part des
manifestants dans le cadre la réponse
est non
quoique non parce que vous avez une
immense majorité de Français qui disent
que cette aspect un apparaît pas comme
étant appréciable mais malgré tout près
d'un Français sur cinq disent oui on
considère que ce mode d'action apparaît
comme étant une moyenne comme d'autres
d'exprimer sa forme de critique à
l'égard de l'action gouvernementale
française sur 5 qui voilà admet ou
approuve la violence des manifestants et
alors si on rentre un peu plus dans le
détail chez ceux qui sont opposants à
cette réforme des retraites alors c'est
surtout en fait de la part des jeunes
d'un côté et de la part qui des
personnes qui sont le plus à gauche sur
l'échiquier politique ou pratiquement un
tiers d'entre eux estiment que ils
approuvent les différentes violences qui
sont utilisées que ce soit en fait une
forme de violence catharsis c'est-à-dire
à l'égard en fait du mobilier urbain ou
autre mais également à l'égard des
forces de l'ordre quelles leçons vont on
peut en tirer ça c'est le concept parce
qu'on sait plusieurs fois vous étiez pas
encore avec nous autour de cette table
mais poser la question de voilà à partir
de jeudi dernier 49-3 on voit une
radicalisation du mouvement on voit que
le
le regard que l'on peut porter à l'égard
de la mobilisation sociale alors c'est
un sondage il est éclairant comment
quelles leçons vous en tirez François
comment vous l'analysez moi je crois que
les Français ils sont un peu comme nous
aussi un truc il nous voit pas il ne
voit pas d'issue et quand dans une
démocratie on ne voit pas d'issue quand
depuis des semaines et des semaines le
pouvoir est sourd
il y a de la colère c'est une colère
ancienne
qui a des fondements sans doute
différents en plus là les étudiants les
lycéens sont entrés dans la danse ça
s'est vu très clairement depuis la
semaine dernière les épreuves anticipées
du bac dans passé voilà bon ça change
aussi l'ambiance
non il y a de la colère alors après moi
je suis je suis un petit peu comme la
personne moyenne de votre sondage je
trouve qu'il y a trop de il y a une
disproportion dans les moyens mais enfin
je n'ai pas de compétences particulières
je n'ai pas d'expertise particulièrement
mais je en revanche on voit on voit
cette colère qui est
qui sortent à l'absence de déboucher
c'était on sait pas qui s'adressait le
Parlement peuvent pas régler pendant
longtemps on a pensé que les
mobilisations que les mobilisations les
sondages d'opinion elle est peser sur le
débat parlementaire ça ne pèse pas on
entend le président de la République
mercredi qui enfin qui fait comme si une
s'était rien passé pratiquement
il y a quand même des raisons de la
colère alors vous parliez des des moyens
notamment des moyens policiers Gérald
Darmanin en cette fin d'après-midi de
lundi annonce 13000 policiers mobilisés
enfin force de l'ordre mobiliser
policier gendarmes dans toute la France
et 5500 à Paris on évoquait la Genèse je
vous propose d'entendre des réactions
étudiants
d'université vous connaissez bien
puisqu'ils sont à la Sorbonne c'est
Romain férié qui est allé à leur
rencontre alors il ne bloque pas mais
ils sont solidaires du mouvement les
écoutes
49-3 ça a été un des déclencheurs mais
il y a aussi le refus de la fin l'échec
de la motion censure qui n'a pas été
voté à 9 mois après donc je pense qu'il
y a eu un espoir pour que la réforme des
retraites soit rejetée ça fait que
effectivement il y a de plus en plus de
jeunes qui se disent que bah non en fait
c'est pas possible que à chaque fois
qu'il y a un espoir pour que le peuple
soit entendu et l'Assemblée nationale
aussi finalement ce soit rejeté de
toutes parts en pleine préparation de
concours nous personnellement et on
comprend totalement et on s'adaptera si
jamais il faut s'adapter et le problème
c'est pas les bloqueurs c'est pas cette
situation là c'est le gouvernement qui
veut pas reculer qui veut pas entendre
la voix des des millions d'opposants à
ce projet là on fait avec les moyens
qu'on a aussi et que le seul moyen
d'être entendu en tant qu'étudiant c'est
malheureusement la mobilisation dans les
universités et le blocus en fait
les blocus et les mobilisations qui ont
lieu aujourd'hui c'est pas seulement
pour les retraites c'est aussi pour
rappeler aux autres que les problèmes il
y en a et l'écoute elle n'est pas là
on le dit la nature du mouvement elle a
elle a un peu évolué on parle presque
moins de la réforme des retraites et
plus finalement de la violence ou de la
verticalité du pouvoir c'est aussi un
peu ce que ce qu'on entend chez ces
étudiants qui baignent dans justement
dans ce contenu politique c'est
intéressant oui précisément et c'est
vrai que c'est un peu le grand absent
d'ailleurs du message présidentiel de
mercredi dernier ou en fait on nous a
parlé du fond nous a réexpliqué la
réforme des retraites mais on nous a
jamais parlé du fait que il y avait eu
cet usage particulier l'Artic 47 1 49-3
44-3 enfin on a eu vraiment un bien
réviser notre droit constitutionnel
parce que précisément il y a eu
peut-être aussi un message de brutalité
au Parlement que voilà les étudiants ont
été à même de de recevoir de comprendre
sur la motion de censure passer à 9 voix
malheureusement pour doucher un peu les
espoirs il y a eu beaucoup de précédents
où les gouvernements se sont maintenus à
très peu de voix près je pense à
Bérégovoy en particulier qui s'est
maintenu à trois voies et on en a bien
sûr plusieurs mais c'est vrai que ce
qu'on se rend compte c'est que
finalement le mouvement je prends de
l'ampleur on a parlé pendant longtemps
de la coagulation des luttes c'était un
peu le mot totem que le gouvernement
voulait pas entendre j'ai vraiment le
sentiment qu'à l'heure actuelle c'est
exactement ce qui se passe c'est à dire
que non seulement la réforme des
retraites ne passent pas mais la manière
dont le gouvernement gouverne ne passe
pas non plus et au fond on a envie en
fait on a un peuple qui a envie de faire
remonter ses revendications cette colère
justement et de faire comprendre que le
pays va mal de manière assez
multifactorielle on le voit sainte
Soline finalement il y avait marqué 49,3
écologique donc en fait on utilise 49-3
citoyens maintenant on a des 49-3 un peu
partout dans cette idée que le peuple a
besoin de se faire entendre c'est ça le
message sur la convergence des lutte
c'est vrai que c'est le vieux rêve des
insoumis notamment et que pour le coup
les insoumis ils ont ils sont pas pour
grand-chose la convergence des luttes se
fait en compte contre la personnalité du
président moi ça m'a frappé dans les
manifestations de la semaine dernière à
Paris c'est vrai que les slogans sur la
retraite étaient passés d'une certaine
façon au second plan ce qui était visé
il les suffit de regarder en fait les
endroits en fait où se déroulent les
mobilisations c'est à dire que c'est pas
des mobilisations qui vont se dérouler
d'un lieu populaire si je dois un petit
peu caricaturer mais qui vont vraiment
se dérouler au sein de Paris même les
lycées ou les qui se mettent en grève ou
qui en fait empêche en fait qu'il puisse
avoir dans lequel il y a des blocages se
situe plutôt en fait dans à Paris par
exemple si on prend la région parisienne
que en Seine-Saint-Denis si on doit
caricaturer quelques peu quoi qu'il en
soit en fait les jeunes ont toujours été
assez critiques à l'égard de la réforme
mais cette critique elle vient de loin
c'est à dire qu'elle s'inscrit pas
uniquement dans le regard qui est porté
à l'égard de la réforme mais autour de
deux aspects 1 une critique à l'égard
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est déjà assez
manifeste et on peut rappeler en fait
que Emmanuel Macron a perdu au cours de
la dernière élection présidentielle la
partie de la jeunesse qu'il avait réussi
à conquérir en 2017 donc ça c'est
peut-être le premier aspect et puis le
deuxième aspect il y a un rapport au
travail de la part des jeunes qui est
d'une manière globale un n'est pas
exactement le même que les générations
plus anciennes et qui deux a été assez
profond modifié ou en tout cas dont le
regard s'est accéléré à la suite de la
période covid où ils vont avoir tendance
à considérer que le travail n'est pas
forcément la même type de finalité que
celle qui avait construit socialement et
politiquement les générations
intérieures alors on a parlé de
verticalité du pouvoir 49-3 évidemment
on va y revenir tout de suite grâce à
Steve journal puisque bonsoir Steve
bienvenue à vous c'est évidemment l'une
des l'une des informations du du
week-end le gouvernement qui joue de la
peinement avec cette promesse
l'utilisation de l'article 49-3 c'est
fini promis c'est fini déclaration
d'Elisabeth borne ce dimanche dans un
entretien accordé à l'AFP la première
ministre nous dit la chose suivante
l'objectif que je fixe pour l'avenir
c'est pas de 49-3 en dehors des textes
financiers on rappelle Thomas que
l'article 49-3 permet de faire passer
une loi sans votes en engageant la
responsabilité du gouvernement c'est ce
qui s'est passé donc sur la réforme des
retraites tous les deux motions de
censure déposées ont été rejetées par
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement
n'est pas tombé le projet de loi a été
adopter alors quelle est la portée de
cette promesse d'Elizabeth borne est-ce
que c'est un engagement politique
important mais surtout là dans l'ordre
du symbolique parce qu'il faut rappeler
depuis une révision constitutionnelle
engagée sous Nicolas Sarkozy en 2008 le
gouvernement ne peut plus faire ce qu'il
veut en la matière l'usage du 49-3 est
limité à un seul texte de loi par
session parlementaire en dehors des
textes budgétaires c'est-à-dire des
projets de loi de finance et de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
ces deux types de textes la première
ministre est no limites en quelque sorte
elle peut le dégainer autant de fois
qu'elle veut c'est précisément pour
cette raison que le gouvernement
d'Elizabeth borne avait initialement
fait le choix de passer par une loi
budgétaire pour faire adopter sa réforme
des retraites ça lui permettait et bien
de se garder sous le coude un 49-3 pour
un autre texte de loi elle annonce donc
à présent qu'elle n'utilisera pas cette
cartouche d'ici à la fin du mois de juin
date de la fin de la session
parlementaire pour sonnerie de Rousseau
l'annonce de la première ministre n'en
est pas une pour Olivier Véran il s'agit
d'une main tendue en direction des
oppositions à côté
elle va arrêter le 49-3 sauf sur les
textes budgétaires à tel dit bon bah
donc elle n'arrête pas les 49-3 qu'ils
arrêtent de nous prétendre pour des
imbéciles on rappelle une détermination
qui est totale qui est travaillée
de pouvoir bâtir texte par texte des
majorités avec la droite et où avec la
gauche
qui a tenté de relativiser l'usage du 43
en avançant des chiffres oui elle fait
les comptes à l'affirme dans son
entretien à l'AFP que depuis le début de
la législature 11 projets de loi ont été
définitivement adoptés et 12
propositions loi il y a eu un recours
aux 49-3 sur trois textes uniquement
sous-entendus mon gouvernement n'a pas
abusé de cette arme pour faire passer
les réformes mais quand on se penche un
peu sur les lois dont on parle la
première ministre on se rend compte
qu'il s'agit de textes qui comporte
plusieurs parties on peut en effet des
Guinée le 49-3 plusieurs fois par projet
de loi au total Elisabeth borne a donc
utilisé 11 fois 7 outils en 10 mois elle
est tout simplement la première ministre
qui en diffuser le plus sous la
Cinquième République depuis Michel
Rocard c'était à la fin des années 80
merci
Steve pour toutes ces explications
Bastien Françoise qu'on n'est pas en
train d'assister à la fin la mort du
49-3 ah oui alors ça c'est on verra mais
mais ça me c'est enfin c'est passionnant
facile effectivement on abandonné parce
que quand on analyse des constitutions
on a généralement dit gravé dans le
marbre la Constitution voilà bon mais en
réalité les constitutions c'est des
choses vivantes dans ces dans leurs
usages par exemple sous la Troisième
République il y avait un droit de
dissolution qui appartenait au président
de la République donc maintenant on l'a
utilisé il s'est planté pour le dire un
peu vulgairement et c'était fini jusqu'à
la fin de la troisième réplique plus
jamais dissolution là peut-être que dans
cette
usage là à a mis un terme aux
à la possibilité même de l'utiliser mais
pourquoi parce que là c'est la question
se pose mais parce que je crois aussi
que
cette crise là elle intervient à un
moment c'est pas un moment tout à fait
nouveau mais à un moment quand même on
est dans une société où ce qui est
acceptable la conception du pouvoir de
l'autorité à beaucoup changé voilà elle
a changé dans les familles on parle plus
à ses enfants comme comme mes parents
ont parlés elle a changé à l'école elle
a changé à l'université évidemment moi
ça fait 35 ans je l'enseigne université
je sais bien qu'on enseigne pas
exactement la même façon hier et
aujourd'hui elle change dans
l'entreprise bon il y a eu aussi des
événements qui qui ont perturbé la
question du covid etc bon et le seul
endroit où ça change pas c'est la
politique et à mon sens
pas une sorte de hasard je sais pas
pourquoi enfin il faudra un jour il
faudra l'analyser le 49-3 est devenu le
symbole
de de la brutalité autoritaire et
verticale et moi j'étais frappé de voir
par exemple mes étudiants me poser des
questions que parce que c'est pas
nouveau on a fait ça donc bon j'explique
ça évidemment chaque année ça choque
généralement personne sauf depuis Valls
moi je pense que c'est la période valse
alors que Emmanuel Valls avait utilisé
le 49 francs de façon assez légitime
c'est pour dans l'esprit de la 5e pour
contraindre sa propre majorité il
s'agissait pas de faire taire les
oppositions et là il y a le 49-3
commence à poser problème et je crois
que le problème en réalité est en
rapport avec l'état de la société par
rapport à la question de l'autorité etc
il faut le rappeler pour lutter contre
une forme d'instabilité politique mais
de la Quatrième République et là il est
facteur d'instabilité sociale voilà ce
49-3 avec le sentiment à chaque fois que
il y a des personnalités qui donne le
sentiment d'être un peu autoritaire
c'était clairement attaché à Manuel
Valls c'est clairement attaché
aujourd'hui à Emmanuel Macron si on
revient en fait au précédent en fait en
tout cas ceux dont on a le plus parlé
Michel Rocard ou Pierre Bérégovoy
n'apparaissait pas enfin en tout cas
n'était pas teinté des mêmes traits
d'image donc il y a et effectivement
l'évolution de la société et également
le portage ou en tout cas le porteur
politique qui s'inscrit dans ce contexte
là en fait Emmanuel Valls on a vu que il
en a fait les frais politiques et quand
bien même lui aussi avait indiqué au
début de sa campagne que il reviendrait
sur le 49-3 et même je crois même qu'il
est proposé de sortir de la Constitution
que ça lui a absolument pas profité et
qui a perdu une primaire interne du
Parti socialiste donc il y a vraiment ce
cette forme de focalisation qui est
olive effectivement faites société
portage politique et au final est-ce que
cette réforme va dans le sens de ce que
l'on souhaite véritablement porter à
l'époque de la loi travail loi el khomri
ce que disait les électeurs de gauche
pas uniquement les députés mais les
électeurs de gauche c'est que ça allait
complètement à rencontre de tout ce qui
était les valeurs et ce qu'ils avaient
pu être amenés à porter dans leur combat
ou dans ce qu'ils avaient pu défendre
depuis des années et des années donc
avec une mesure qui apparaissait comme
étant orthogonale et là on le sait sur
les 64 ans les Français ils sont
profondément opposés il l'avait dit dès
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron et il le
redisent à nouveau lorsqu'il critiquent
l'usage du 49-3 juge juste sur le
message qu'on voit parce qu'on a quand
même eu un gouvernement qui a choisi ce
47 ans et se plfsr pour avoir un 49-3
gratos si j'ose dire voilà ensuite on
nous a cessé de nous dire oh non on veut
pas en faire on va essayer une majorité
possible surtout dans les derniers jours
dans le vote on en fait un on dit bah
non mais c'est tout à fait démocratique
c'est la Constitution le permet et là
c'est énorme mais promis on en fera plus
donc ça leur brûle les doigts 59 3 kiki
osera encore utiliser le 493
breaking news que Elisabeth borne ne
l'utilisera pour des textes financiers
puisqu'elle ne l'a jusqu'à présent
utiliser pour des textes financiers il
faut bien le rappeler et que les 11 fois
sont sur le projet de budget et le
projet de budget rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale néanmoins je pense
qu'il faut pas mettre tous les mots sur
la constitution de la 5e République ou
sur le 49-3 en tant que tel puisque ces
derniers temps on est on est dans une
très grande vague de 6e République alors
évidemment ça peut tout à fait être
porté il y a beaucoup de choses qu'il
faudrait réformer dans cette cinquième
mais encore une fois on a parlé du du
porteur et du portage n'oublions pas que
la méthode autour de ce 49-3 est en fait
celle qui est critiquée dans la rue
c'est à dire que c'est pas l'article qui
rationalise une majorité qui pose
problème au peuple et là je vous rejoins
vraiment c'est je pense que c'est la
manière dont la Constitution est vécue
dans la société il y a beaucoup changé
et surtout la manière dont ce 49-3 est
utilisé discipliné une majorité c'était
vraiment son objectif initial mais en
arriver à utiliser tous les mécanismes
du parlementarisme rationalisé en moins
de 15 jours sur une discussion qui
finalement aurait mérité peut-être deux
ans pour être accepté c'est vraiment ça
qui a créé une hiatus merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce premier